[Applause]
[Music]
and I just wanted to begin by explaining
what the periodic table means to
chemists like me
[Music]
oh and there she blows I'm expected to
be quite safe Wow running poor Mackey
boom exciting night for Rita royal water
[Music]
P for phosphorus
rather that was a really really
energetic reaction
[Music]
molten iron oh cool
and the gloves is also key
[Music]
now this is one of my favourite lumps of
matter in the world
[Music]
whoa
and really quite excited so potassium
and nectar is very reactive one of my
colleagues who used to work with it
described this as evil
so if we're doing color change reaction
[Music]
and then this table to analyse touches
balloon
Oh
they place messenger raise up our cesium
on a piece of street
you can see the doctor sulfur's burning
wing intense Tina
[Music]
start you can see that it's so hot you
see put a pouring water I've managed to
decimate
[Music]
and
we're gonna need more elements
[Music]
three two one
lovely